PLEASE BE ADVISED AN AUDIO
VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING MADE
OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
FLORA GRAYSON KAMLAGER-DOVE
HERE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RIVAS
YEAH WICKS WE HAVE A FORM
OF A QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT TO
JELLO THERE'S A MOTION BY
MISTER MATHIS SECONDED BY HAS
COME UNDER DONE THE
QUESTION ON OF THE REFERRAL BASE
CA TWELVE UNDERSTANDS PROCEDURAL
-- AT THIS POINT BUT THIS IS
THIS VOTE TODAY DOESN'T IN NO
WAY SHOW SUPPORT FOR THIS ACA
TWELVE THAT IS CORRECT THE STRIP
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER ON
US -- WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CUNNINGHAM
HI CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLORA HI GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK
SILVA I RAMOS ON THE SIDE
RIVAS RIVAS AYE WORKS MOTION
PASSES MOTIONS PASSED THIS
RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED